- [Marchers] Macy's, Macy's Day Parade.
- [Narrator] Macy's is
the brand long identified
with the kickoff of the
holiday shopping season.
And for years, it spent big
to identify its star logo
with star power.
- Almost midnight!
- Macy's black Friday sale.
- [Narrator] But lately it
hasn't been all holiday cheer.
And that was before the coronavirus crisis
forced it to temporarily
shutter its doors.
The retailer has fared better
than some of its peers.
In the first half of 2020,
18 major retailers have filed
for Chapter 11 protection.
Macy's has not, but the
historic company is hurting,
raising questions about how
far it's star could fall.
Macy's first opened as a dry
goods store on 14th street
in Manhattan in 1858.
Near the turn of the century,
two German Jewish immigrant brothers,
Nathan and Isidor Straus
bought a controlling interest
in the company.
And in 1902, they moved it 20 blocks north
to the store's present flagship
location at Herald Square.
It became part of an upscale
New York shopping district
known as Ladies' Mile.
The brothers took the
company public in 1911
on the New York Stock Exchange.
The following year, Isidor Straus died,
along with his wife, Ida,
in the Titanic disaster.
Nathan Strauss continued
growing the business.
And in 1924, the company
expanded to take over
nearly the entire block
across from Herald Square.
And the retailer heralded
itself as the largest store
in the world.
That same year, 10,000 people gathered
in front of his store to
watch a small procession,
which would eventually become
the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade.
The company survived the Great Depression.
And by the mid 1940s,
with American servicemen
returning home from World
War II, business was booming.
Single-day holiday sales
past a million dollars
for two years straight,
which would be more than
14 million dollars today.
During the Cold War,
the brand became a symbol
of American capitalism
and consumer choice.
The store was shown off
to a top communist leader
during his 1959 diplomatic
visit to the US.
- [Reporter] Before the store opens,
(indistinct) is escorted through Macy's
for a cross section of what's
offered the American shopper.
- [Narrator] The company
expanded around the country.
By the mid 1970s, it had a
chain of 72 department stores
in 10 States.
Sales grew into the 1980s.
Then in 1986, the
retailer's Chairman and CEO,
Edward Finkelstein took
the company private
in a 3.5 billion dollar
leveraged buyout deal.
- And the leverage buyout
loaded the company with debt
and that debt eventually tipped it
into bankruptcy protection.
- [Narrator] In 1994, Federated, a rival
department store chain based in Ohio,
agreed to acquire the brand.
- They bought Macy's out of bankruptcy.
And then you fast forward to 2005
when Federated at the
time was the number one
department store chain in the country,
it merged with the number-two player,
May Department Stores Company.
And renamed itself Macy's,
and that's where we get
the sort of current
incarnation of Macy's, Inc.
- [Narrator] It was a
landmark deal that created
the first truly national
department store chain
with stores from coast.
- And they had beloved brands,
Marshall Fields in Chicago, Filene's.
They had sort of these local
brands around the country
that they eventually did
away with and renamed
all the stories Macy's.
- [Narrator] Federated
sought to give all of them
a coherent image with
splashy national TV ads
that starred the celebrities
who sold branded products in their stores.
- [Spokesperson] Only one
star can bring all these stars
together, that's the magic of Macy's.
- It's good to be back here at Macy's.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm very excited for my new shoe line.
- [Narrator] And then the economy tumbled.
- [Reporter] Signs of a
recession we're in the air,
between dismal retail figures
and the subprime mortgage crisis.
- [Narrator] In 2008, the Great Recession
brought a sharp slowdown
in consumer spending.
And steep losses to the
company's balance sheet.
- The Great Recession of 2008,
was challenging for all the
brick and mortar chains,
and Macy's in particular
struggled during that period.
- [Narrator] It wasn't until 2010,
that Macy's returned to profitability,
thanks in part to double-digit
growth in online sales.
By this point, it operated more than
800 department stores in the US.
- [Reporter] For the first
time, all 800 Macy's stores
will open at midnight on Thanksgiving.
- [Narrator] But for the
retailer and its peers,
the post-recession good
times didn't last long.
- All of a sudden, the impact
of Amazon and online shopping
really started to eat into
their sales and margins,
and traditional brick
and mortar chains woke up
to the reality that they
had way too many stores.
And chains like Macy's, The Gap,
these beloved sort of retail brands
that were in every mall
started closing stores.
- Big box retailer Macy's is
saying goodbye to three malls
right here in Hampton Roads,
leaving a big impact on
more than 250 employees.
- And a big heartbreak
to thousands of shoppers.
- [Narrator] The company continued
cutting costs, closing stores.
And in 2014, it laid off
1800 workers to try to save
a hundred million dollars a year.
The good news for Macy's,
it had an online strategy
that was working.
Macy's.com became the seventh most popular
online store in the US.
But online sales proved
to be less profitable.
- For traditional retailers like Macy's,
shifting your business online,
presents particular challenges.
Online sales tend to be
less profitable than sales
in a physical store.
You've got all kinds of,
shipping costs really eat
into the profit margin.
- [Narrator] Then came the pandemic.
- [Reporter] Businesses across country
forced to shut their doors,
already leading to
absolutely stunning increases
in unemployment claims.
- All that inventory
literally got locked inside.
And now it's become an
aging asset inside stores
across the country.
- The country's shut down and
people aren't buying stuff.
- [Narrator] After months-long closures,
beginning in March of 2020,
Macy's posted over 900
million dollars in losses
for the first three quarters of 2020.
Despite this, it was in a
better position to survive
than many of its peers.
- Well, the lessons they learned
from their leveraged buyout
in the '80s really stayed with them.
And for a retailer to
take on too much debt
is very perilous.
This is what has pushed
a lot of companies,
from JC Penny, to Neiman Marcus,
to J.Crew into bankruptcy.
- [Narrator] To avoid debt,
the retailer already had plans
before the pandemic to
close a fifth of its stores
over the next three years.
And on top of that, in June,
it said it planned to lay off
nearly 4,000 corporate staffers.
A Macy spokesperson says
that by reorganizing
how the company's structured
and reducing costs,
it's in a good position
to win with customers
and emerge a stronger company.
- Not all the stores look great.
I mean, they've got
maybe half their fleet,
they've been investing in and upgrading,
and making into kind of marquee locations.
Macy's has to find a reason to exist.
Why should customers come to
its stores when they can get
so many of the products
it sells elsewhere?
And sometimes for lower prices.
- [Narrator] One positive for Macy's,
as its competitors fold,
the company has a chance
to pick up market share.
Most stores have reopened,
and it's still got
the annual marketing bonanza
that is the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade.
Though, in 2020, it will
be a television-only event
without the in-person crowds.